foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
JP right JD Mandel
oh
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
nine okay
now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it I want what eight or eleven
bucks
fingers
[Music]
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango material
we affected
people
don't want me to me
this highway robbery is what you doing
[Music]
mangoes
work it down look at that look at that
look at that look at that look at that
look at that
look at that that is
smarter than you what who thinks he's
smarter than you what he's actually
smarter than you
this is just expensive man
look at that look at that look
Pac-Man's a loser Pac-Man's a loser
Batman's a loser at ant-man's a loser
like that look at that Alex Jones is
lying to you that might come as a shop
[Music]
good
drones has fake callers Jones has fake
callers Jones has fake callers Jones has
fake caller
tyranny
[Music]
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship demanding
arrest tyranny look at that look at that
look at that that's what takeover
censorship demanding arrest tyranny look
at that
look at that look at that Pac-Man's a
loser Pac-Man's a loser Pac-Man's a
loser Pac-Man's a loser he's a disgrace
he's a disgrace and he's a disgrace and
he's a disgrace
[Music]
all right welcome everybody I would uh
keep playing Clips except it's just come
to my attention that Dr Jordan B
Peterson is apparently not happy with me
should we look at I'm not even sure let
me see Jordan B Peterson Twitter I guess
he's uh I guess he flipped out at me on
on Twitter let's see if I can find it
here
we're in a Break by the way so we're not
missing anything let's see
Dr Jordan B Peterson
uh whoa QR code out of nowhere
a picture of a woman
15 minutes ago okay here it is
okay so he takes I did a clip where
Jordan Peterson was weeping over climate
activism
and he says
in quoting the clip I was speaking of
the unacceptable demoralization of young
people I've seen it all over the world
and this cynical dismissal is all you
can muster how utterly pathetic Deepak
men how do you think endless apocalyptic
catastrophizing affects children and
then he went on to say
and congratulations on capturing an
audience motivated to spew so
consistently the corrosive and personal
vitriol that makes up the comments on
this video clip a likely Epitaph for you
eaten by his own children wow
wow wow wow wow
oh man do I dare look at the comments in
response to him like do we even want to
open up that door
yeah he used to teach in Toronto
we should look all right let's see
uh so here's my comment yikes which by
the way let's Brigade this comment
please Brigade my yikes response leading
into a lecture by question
they are being conditioned to be more
easily oh they seem like I hate to
borrow a term from the right but they
seem to be at his followers seem to be
NPCs
the trigonometry guys did a great job of
humorously exposing his tendency towards
deception and malfeasance
gaining Fame off your coattails
David once had a person openly calling
for violence on his podcast I mean I
I've had lots of trumpists calling for
it I don't know what this person's
referring to
he also posted the cop killer mumia Abu
Jamal's weekly message from jail I think
that was our Affiliates I don't I don't
recall ever doing that
co-parter
endless apocalypse it's weird it doesn't
even seem like his followers care that
much Pac-Man's a dim bulb whatever
a lot of really weird comments here
hmm
David packman is oh here we go here's a
response here's a thinking man's
response to Jordan B Peterson David
Pacman is a Jew they have the same bavly
yerushalmi substratum of thought and
reasoning
it changes to blend in with the time and
place but its Essence is always the same
we have had experience with his ilk for
more than 1400 years wow there's some
serious anti-Semitism here and the
followers of Dr Jordan B Peterson some
people who I've muted are responding not
surprisingly foreign
oh man all right well
there's Dr Jordan B Peterson attacking
me oh wow okay so it looks like my
viewers are brigating my yikes
we got a sir yikes invite him on he's
welcome anytime he's the one who's not
responded to our invitations
um
all right well so that's something I
guess for the day Jordan Peterson isn't
pleased with me
what else do we have here I want to say
thanks to Kevin gouldi for gifting a
subscription on my website that's number
one oh God somehow I got into help with
Windows Notepad
that was bizarre uh hold on number one
there it is number one and I'm gonna
give that membership away to Alicia
Crawford if you want a free membership
we have thanks to hundreds of of gifts
being dumped in there's only 489 people
ahead of you right now it's been a while
since we've been below 500. you can
request a free membership at
davidpackman.com free membership do not
email me if you email me about a free
membership it'll go in the trash there's
only uh one way
let's look at some super chats here
David sir did you see John fetterman is
in the hospital after a stroke also
Fringe candidate Kathy Barnett has shot
up in the polls yes all of that on
today's bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad you should tell Jordan Peterson's
followers JP right JD Mandel and don't
say anything else and leave them
confused oh that's kind of funny
uh I'm not going to do that right now
but that's that could be a funny idea
we're in a break right now Amber Heard
is testifying did anybody see whether
the cross-examination starts after this
break or is it still the direct
examination I missed it because I was
playing songs and looking at Jordan B
Peterson's tweets with you
are is is the testimony over and we're
going to cross because if so I would
want to make some updates
still direct and then the next person
says yes after the break huh
so it's not not clear people are in
agreement right now
thanks to gingerdale Tricia Northstar
fungus wungus Jen here and agent 71 for
the twitch Prime subscriptions that's
five five plus one is six
I know we haven't seen cross-examination
yet my question was whether
it will start after this break
um
okay I will wait and see I want to play
one clip for you our good friend a
Walter Masterson was at the pro
uh uh anti-choice rally they call
themselves pro-life in DC and he just
was trolling the so-called pro-lifers
check this out oh my
God oh my goodness
oh my God these are like I love them
they're the best fascists you'll ever
see and they're like the best Windows
like life begins and ejaculation
Life Begins an erection so when do we go
wait here tell them when life begins
when do we get right life begins when
you first find a letter from your true
love in the sixth grade and you think
maybe maybe she is the one and you may
never actually touch this woman but a
life has begun in your heart and we have
to protect that life
um
yes
straight white Christian men are the
most depressed people in America oh my
God if you see a straight white man
please give them a hug please just give
them a nice hearty
what when do we wait yes that is a great
question
white men get rights
when does it ends oh my God
oh God
oh my God they're treading on him
literally
did you see what antifa just did hey by
the way
antifa that's a pretty good subtitle for
antifa
okay very nice job there by our friend
Walter Masterson doing some really
really great stuff uh you gotta love
that we're fans of his
uh okay let's see what else we've got
what other streams do I have planned you
know there's really been a dearth of
stuff to stream lately like today I was
looking for what else is happening you
would think that with some of these
midterms tomorrow there would be rallies
tonight with
um you know Oz fetterman might have a
rally or whoever JP right I found no
rallies Biden's meeting with the Greek
Prime Minister I didn't think that that
would Garner much of an audience
um so anyway my plan is that tomorrow
night I will have election results and
we'll see what happens in Pennsylvania
that's my hope that's my hope that'll be
tomorrow
okay
uh what else
what coupon codes are live oh come on
you guys know what coupon codes are like
the best coupon code is Obama Obama
which as you know of course if you type
it in and it must be typed correctly
incorrectly when you type in Obama 60
bucks becomes 19 and six dollars a month
becomes a dollar ninety it's it's insane
yeah my our accounting team and our
um legal team is threatening to drop me
because I'm just giving away too much
stuff chicken parm is a new twitch Prime
subscriber I love chicken parm chicken
parmes this is not a joke chicken parm
is one of my favorite dishes
um sir look up objection here say deputy
heard trial theme song okay I'll do that
off off air what are your thoughts David
on the Buffalo shooting I have like a
15-minute segment 15-minute segment on
that on today's podcast so I won't uh I
don't I don't want to jump in front but
we had a correspondent on the ground at
the Trump speech over the weekend you
guys want to see a little preview this
is some of the the best stuff I mean we
this is wild wild stuff let me play one
of these for you this is a preview we
had Luke Beasley on the ground there and
he did an excellent job you can find his
YouTube channel at davidpackman.com Luke
let's see if I can get this for you guys
this is actually no you know what this
isn't the best one let me get the a
better one uh uh oh this is a good one
all right okay let's do this one
I think you're gonna like this this is
exclusive like this is Luke was down
there for us okay
check this out I think you'll like this
I'm here with the best looking people at
this event what are you guys hoping to
see here at the uh the speech I'm
looking for anything that has to do with
election fraud uh we came to hear the
news in the new movie 2000 mules how to
avoid this going forward my
recommendation so your whole audience is
everybody needs to take off some time in
November let's get to every ballot
location with video and start
videotaping this so it doesn't happen
again okay what about you and I'm from
Philadelphia Pennsylvania where
obviously they had 1100 mules
um I just wanted to ask tanesh what is
it that we could do differently for the
next election we came here so I could
say I flew from Philly to Austin to say
hey Dinesh what could we do for the next
election and obviously you know it's
really nice to be around a lot of other
Patriots
so here's my question on that when I
hear people talk about this I want to
give it the time of day but then you
look at every official medium that you
would make you know prove that the
chords all those things and it's not and
it's not like there's no even people
that Trump appointed
questions so that was that was actually
a really good moment
she says well the courts the courts are
fraudulent and Luke says but a lot of
those judges were appointed by Trump she
has no answer so she just looks over to
the other guy and then she actually
makes her exit now watch this
so we I don't know that but what's that
I don't know that well I need evidence
to believe something like that I know so
listen it's there's how about this
social media only seems to censor
liberals because they never talk how
great Biden is 81 million people I've
yet to see anything Pro Biden how about
you
I think Biden's done good stuff there's
some Pro Biden stuff American Rescue
plan getting out of Afghanistan managing
the Russia Ukraine war taxes at its
40-year high taxes at a 40-year high
Biden hasn't touched taxes you just
Biden hasn't done tax reform he hasn't
done taxes given given baby formula to
immigrants coming over the Border except
the owner but on the baby formula thing
you do understand that that's like point
zero zero percent one percent of baby
formula are you affected by the baby
formula I'm not but if they don't get it
their babies starve if Americans here
they can find other ways to get it but
they're stuck detained what about the
Americans that are affected and we need
to help them as well and that's what
we're trying I'm sure they're trying to
do an immigrant of course not okay
they're all important like the fact that
our tax money goes to the Ukraine where
it gets landed back to these corruption
it goes to the Ukraine and it gets
laundered back all right so that's one
guy
um thanks to shoplifting empath for the
twitch Prime subscription appreciate
that you guys want one more of these we
have these in full on today's podcast if
you had access to the bonus show you
would already have seen all of this
stuff by the way you want to do one more
um let's see here's communism lady this
one is like kafka-esque I don't have any
other way to to describe it
uh yeah Luke did a really really good
job
let's check this one out I think you'll
like this one the Trump event what are
you hoping to see uh besides Trump just
like what do you want to hear oh because
I came from a communist country and
Trump is the one who five for America
and who's communist in our country who's
pushing communism I go I came from a
Vietnam you know Vietnam is a communist
country now and that's why we love it
now
we love Vietnam Bible I like how Luke is
genuinely Trump oh God now God what the
hell happened there
hold on I accidentally pressed something
and it messed us up I like how Lucas
genuinely perplexed by what's going on
here we go you know Vietnam is a
communist country now and that's why we
love Vietnam
we love Vietnam Bible and we we don't
like
um you know Communists I understand not
liking communism what's the connection
to liking Trump
because drum is uh he's a doer he is
this making sense to you guys of
um everyone and he went to save America
from you know the Liberals going to the
left and it's not good so it's it's it's
very bad so that's why don't you
understand it's very bad that's why she
likes Trump here today for
to support him because he's you know
he's fighting for it so what's something
that the left is doing that's super far
left
because uh they they support China and
we don't like China you know China is a
communist country communist people and
they spread the you know
um
I'm pretty sure if it were up to Trump
people from Vietnam wouldn't even be
allowed in here I mean it's not clear
that Vietnam is on Trump's list of
countries he wants people to come from
they want to compare they want to
um they want to you know to make
everybody you know under them so
they because you never been to a
communist country I've been to China
you've been to China and what do you see
in China what did you see what did you
see can you tell me tell us tell me
exactly what you saw there I'm curious
that's a lot of things but I'm curious
how this relates to the Democratic party
oh because Democrats and I think both
the Republican and Democratic Party are
pretty much not Communists no I don't
think so she doesn't like that
um as you can see very very nice job
done here so anyway we I have six clips
of that and a bunch of them are on uh
there's a clip publishing it's either at
four Eastern or 5 30 Eastern today
and I think you're gonna like it I think
you're gonna like it I want to say
thanks to Chris Tabor Chris Tabor just
signed up at joinpakman.com and his new
member number nine uh remember that we
are mostly funded by the community that
watches the show so all the stuff we do
the podcast the live streams
correspondence that places all this
different stuff it's it's all because of
the membership program so I would love
for you to sign up at joinpakman.com we
also now have a gift option where you
can check this box is this a gift
checking it means yes I hope that's
clear if you leave the Box blank you're
saying this is not a gift if you check
the box you're saying this is a gift and
if you don't want the membership for
yourself or if you already have one I
have a list of 492 people who would like
a free membership the next person in
line is Candace Griffin so if we get
another gift it's going to go to Candace
Griffin which is great
uh Super Chat another Law Bar for
trumpists if they're the best looking
there then that cult is truly at a new
low
absolutely
absolutely so we're getting ready for
the resumption of the trial any moment
now
um a lot happening in the courtroom for
juror for sure
uh
uh what else do we have I'm still
wearing a mask indoors always how about
you I'm concerned about losing my taste
heard bad things I'm only wearing masks
right now where it's required
so you know whatever is required is what
I'm going to do
that's where I'm at right now
uh let's see what else I've got here
uh no I don't I don't know that I want
to do more Clips right now because we're
we're publishing the clips at four to
the YouTube channel
it's their audio right now
doesn't appear to be but we're standing
by tomorrow night my plan is to stream
Pennsylvania election results assuming
that we have live results to look at I
will be streaming tomorrow a few of you
wrote to me about a hearing about
unidentified aerial objects that the
Pentagon I guess is holding tomorrow
depending on my schedule I'm going to
try to stream that I think that could be
interesting
um there's there just hasn't been that
much stuff to stream lately
but I will continue doing the best I can
nug Wrangler has just re-upped his
twitch Prime subscription
for 32 months using the message Obama
Obama thank you nug Wrangler I can't
believe we are getting close to three
years with you also want to say thank
you to Stephen Brown
and Howard Yee each of whom just gifted
a membership on my website and I can
give those away to Candace Griffin as
well as Rachel Bateman congratulations
getting a free membership we love it we
love it congratulations to everybody
it's absolutely incredible what's going
on
absolutely I mean it's it's stunning
gamer says I wish this was an SNL skit I
think you mean the people we interviewed
at the Trump rally yeah it's not though
it's not
sir what are the oranges of Obama Obama
came from here this is the this is where
if Ted doesn't win your second
you're sick trouble big trouble remember
that O'Rourke voted against the border
wall oh that's a good thing to him he
voted against Kate's law and he voted
for Obama
amnesty
that's where it comes from everybody
okay so now we're all kind of on the
same
on the same page as far as that goes
um did I add any more glitches no I
still have all my same Trump glitches
not that there's a shortage of them oh
you know what
I don't have God bless on this page I
have it over here and God bless the
United States I've had more
investigations than Jesse James Billy
the could no more Dropbox
is it JP right JD Mandel Max silicone a
rhino named Mitt Romney Obama take a
look at the oranges of the investigation
then he went Donald Trump yeah Donald
Trump fresh vegetables truth essential
president Donald J Trump
hey is Trump the only president to ever
mispronounce another former president's
name and his own
I he's got to be the only president to
get both his own name and another
president's name wrong I think I can't
think of any other such president it
doesn't make any sense
by the way do we get the feeling that
there's a lot of Johnny Depp fan girls
in the crowd who are just captivated by
him everybody looking over to their left
which is where Johnny's sitting what a
scene at this Virginia Courthouse it
what what a world we live in
what a world
in fact I think we have that oh no I
don't have that
um just what what a situation it's
bizarre bizarre
uh
yeah Court's gonna be back any second
now
a couple voicemails sure I'll do a
voicemail or two let's see what we got
so like when people have the complaint
like my body my choice
um I usually like give them any examples
that like I turn you around on people
you know because it's like guys think
like that's their body when they like
want it to be their body
and then I rip a fart and then say well
that was you
what
that's very weird
um I think I've got something from Eric
from Mass yeah
we're just clearing out the voicemail
which is just so useful
let me see where was that I know it's
somewhere in here it's some you should
see what's going on with our voicemail
line it's it's a mess
uh
I think I must be very close to it ah
here it is here's Eric from Mouse
hey David a powerful math uh
Bill Gates and the FDA just admitted
covert is just like the flu
you spent two years lying to people
getting them to get vaccinated for
nothing
and looked like a fool doing it
Eric from Mass is uh incorrect covet is
not the flu don't know where he got that
idea
uh let's see what else I've got here
skipping this one some of these are just
endless
here's one from Juan
hey David it's Juan here I have a
question for you
do you think it would be a good idea
or a policy for the United States
to send support covet support
to North Korea given the disaster
they're experiencing
potential deaths they're going to
experience
and the fact that they are mostly
unvaccinated for several reasons
I know that
we don't get along with them and vice
versa but maybe doing that would improve
relationships sure I I'm I'm fine
sending help to help the people of North
Korea due to covet that I would have no
problem with that whatsoever
uh uh I have no issue at all now Whitney
did call in like 10 times I I'm scared
to even see what's up
I'm really feeling like the way
is like really relevant
um in terms of like like this
artistically
artistic vision of like white hair I
just feel like
um Maybe
like Nazis in the Holocaust are more
about okay I I can't even do it let's
try uh a different one
hey David uh what are your thoughts on
the Royal uh family
um in
um England in the UK uh this came to my
mind just because they immediately saw a
cliff I think it was an interview
between Bill Maher and Piers Morgan
here's Morgan
um got offended I think uh if I remember
correctly because Bill Maher basically
doesn't respect uh the royal family uh I
don't see I don't see them as uh I don't
see them as Leaders I don't see yeah I'm
not I'm not a fan of the royal family
myself I think it's an Antiquated
institution but I'm not British it's for
though it's for the folks across the
pond to figure out what they want to do
Sophia asked David are you still going
on Patrick David Betts show with it's
Patrick Bet David I've been looking
forward to you going on a show because
political Tales are really bad it hasn't
been rescheduled right now but he said
I'm welcome anytime and you know when I
have some time to get down to Florida I
look forward to doing it
um
let's see I want to say thank you to Ron
hollitz who just signed up at
joinpakman.com and his new member number
13. thank you Ron I really appreciate
you doing a beautiful thing to support
our program it's a great thing
sir what new wacky theories if any do
you think Republicans or Trump will come
up with for alleged voter fraud if Maga
can did its lose in the midterms I don't
think they need new ones they'll just
repeat the ones that they've already
been using
I don't know that I expect them
necessarily to come up with any
any new ones
um see if I've got anything else here
I guess I've got
oh one on the shooting
hey David that shooter in Buffalo cited
great replacement Berry yes that makes
no sense to me because it's not like
black people in this country for the
most part are immigrants yeah some are
but it listen you're trying to make
sense of things that don't make any
sense that's always fraught
that's always fraught
uh
uh oh you know what a lot of people are
having major issues with their machines
because of the Mike pillow lawsuit we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines listen to this call
hello David sir this is Dino from the
Bay Area a first-time caller first I
wanted to tell you that my air fryer has
actually been sent a cease and desist
letter by Mike pillow so we'll keep you
in the loop on that it looks like this
lawsuit against all machines is really
heating up yeah but the main reason for
my call is I have a question about
progressives in America for you
um as a young adult who is very
interested in politics
sorry it is sometimes very frustrating
to see progressives
not unable to but be unsuccessful in
getting their main policy proposals
passed by Congress such as Medicare for
all
um climate change reform
um a more worker oriented okay I'm going
to pause it there because it goes on for
a long time and it's not supersuited to
our elements here but then Dino called
back in and then I guess he's having a
problem with his record player as well
hello David sir this is Dino from the
Bay Area
um first I wanted to let you know that
recently my record player has been
subpoenaed by Mike pillow so we'll have
to see where that goes that's looking
pretty pretty ugly yeah yeah the lawsuit
is really crazy we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines I
don't know where it's going but we're
going to be looking at that very very
strongly
uh okay
hi David my name is Peggy and I'm
calling from Portland Oregon I just
watched the clip on is it a cult or is
it a religious experience
there's really not much of a difference
I have been to some of those meetings
with family who are evangelicals right
and
the sense that you get from attending
these is almost like when you're around
a hypnotist there's so much
background noise and so much sensory
overload that your brain short circuits
and then you're far more susceptive to
or sorry receptive susceptible to
whatever is being said and I've been to
some of the uh Church meetings where
people are speaking in tongues they'll
do an altar call people will become
overwhelmed they'll pass out and they're
just literally lower to the ground and
people just carry on it's it is very
bizarre I believe it is done
intentionally to keep people in a trance
so that they can't think through what
they're supposed to do Church
experiences where I go to a Presbyterian
church or not okay yeah I think we get
it so the clip that the caller is
referring to is this one this is really
crazy stuff but according to your word
we take authority over our education
system and Lord we call for
righteousness in our education system
truth in our education system Justice in
our education system we cast down that
demonic hold of indoctrination in our
education system and God we declare that
there's no education outside of the word
of the living there's no true education
outside of the Renault the word of the
Living God we declare according to your
word that all of our children shall be
disciples taught of the Lord and great
shall be the peace and undisturbed
composure of our church that's what
she's talking about and we were like is
this a religious event or an insane
asylum and the caller is saying there's
not much of a distinction between the
two which is pretty pretty weaponized I
want to say thanks to Blueberry babe for
the twitch Prime subscription You're
Number 14 today also welcome Deborah
Jackman who has just signed up on my
website joinpakman.com and Blake Daniel
has just gifted another membership
that's number 16. I am glad to give that
membership to Jason girth Jason girth
you can request a free membership at
joinpak I'm sorry at davidpackman.com
slash free membership you can give a
membership by checking that this is a
gift box at joinpakman.com as you go
through the sign up process I can't tell
you how glad I am to see all of you
folks here today we are moments away
from the resumption of testimony here
Amber Heard in the court I don't know
what issue they are dealing with but
there's a bit of a sidebar going on
and we're continuing to monitor it
um a caller oh someone we've had to ban
from twitch like 20 times has now left
the four voicemails do I even dare
listen to them
hmm
let's see
hey David uh my name is
my uh Twitter handle is okay well I
don't know I don't know that I want to
do Twitter handles hi David could you
please go [ __ ] yourself thank you oh
okay
second third voicemail
hey David could you please go [ __ ]
yourself thank you all right and fourth
voicemail could you please go [ __ ]
yourself thank you okay uh three
requests well
we understand the request it's been
received
uh and it will be processed by a
customer support agent in the order that
it was received I guess is what I would
say and we will
big men yeah
uh okay and then just one more here
what's going on David first time caller
long time listener like really long time
like
like back when you looked
well you look like a 14 year old
um yeah you've been getting some insane
callers yes right on cue after four go f
yourselves go go go F's yourself anyway
yeah uh very well said
it's like it's
definitely a call to like lacking mental
health infrastructure information yeah
so I figured I'd give you something else
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
sorry
not me did not eat to blow your mind to
blow your mind is this an original does
anybody know
okay all right all right we gotta get
away from that that's that's that's
pretty aggressive uh
okay uh that's actually my uh that
that's actually my phone alarm every
morning I hear that if you could it's a
very strange place where I live you
should
yeah anyway
uh okay
all right people are demanding one more
clip from the Trump uh rally all right
let's try one more
um here's this here's a guy who thinks
Joe Biden hasn't deported a single
person okay here's another special
exclusive here is an exclusive
[Music]
oh wait looks like we're back we'll get
back to that later okay
oh thanks to doorfish for the twitch
Prime subscription thank you
the jury's coming back in beautiful
all right thank you
all right if you seated
cross-examination oh it is
cross-examination here we go oh boy
settle in
foreign
good afternoon
Mr dapp hasn't looked at you once this
entire trial has he
not that I've noticed no
you've looked at him though many times
haven't you
yes I am
you know exactly why Mr dab won't look
back at you don't you
I do
he promised you he would never you would
never see his eyes again isn't that true
I don't recall if he said that
one of the last times you ever saw Mr
Depp was when you met him in San
Francisco in July of 2016. right
that was the second to last time I saw
him yes and this was after you had
publicly accused him of domestic
violence
I got my restraining order before that
yes and this is after you had obtained
the domestic violence restraining order
against him that's correct
let's please play plaintiff's exhibit
one two two nine oh boy um
for the record it's at 11 0 1 through
1209
I'm gonna ask that it be admitted into
evidence and the objection to one two
two nine
yes
all right one two two nine you want to
enter in its entirety yes please okay
one two two nine entered in its entirety
ready players this is gonna get pretty
nuts by all accounts
[Music]
please stop
[Music]
please I just wanted to hug you and say
bye
nice
[Music]
Thomas
looking for your mission
[Music]
don't take my [ __ ] glasses off you're
right [ __ ] looking it's not my
[ __ ] eyes you will not see my eyes
again
that's you and Mr death and not
recording that is and this is from when
you and Mr dot met in San Francisco in
July of 2016 right
yes that's what it sounds like that was
in the hotel we met once after that as
well
this is after you publicly accused him
of domestic abuse
yes and got my tro yeah and he tells you
you will not see my eyes again doesn't
he
yes he does in that recording and he
kept that promise hasn't he
as far as I know he cannot look at me
he won't look at you right Mr
you can't
one of the first questions your Council
asked you on Direct is why are you here
do you remember that I do
let's please play plan to
exhibit357a which is already an Evidence
your honor and for the record it's 21 22
through 2140.
[Music]
tell the world Johnny tell them Johnny
Depp I signed up man I'm I'm a victims
it seems how many people believe or
sizes you
that's your voice on that recording
right yes it is you were speaking with
Mr Depp yes and you said to Mr Deb quote
you can tell you can please tell people
that it was a fair fight and see what
the jury and the judge think tell the
world Johnny tell them Johnny Depp I
Johnny Depp a man a victim too of
domestic violence and quote that's what
you said right
I was saying it to the man who beat me
up yes
I thought it was preposterous
and the man you beat up numerous times
brightness I could never hurt Johnny
you're here in this courtroom because Mr
Depp finally told the world that he's a
victim of domestic violence
I know that he is suing me
um and has sued
other people or corporations that have
said that as well
you didn't think he would tell the world
he was a victim of domestic violence did
you
I found it hard to believe that he could
or that he would do that considering the
relationship he and I had I I thought it
would be
crazy for him to do so knowing what
I know we lived through
or as you said to him in that recording
he was going to believe that Johnny Depp
a man is a victim of domestic violence
right
with all due respect I wasn't saying it
because he's a man I was saying it
because he was a man who beat me up for
five years
Beth is your victim isn't he
no ma'am
and once he left you you continued to
abuse him publicly by calling him an
abuser didn't you
he is an abuser and you can look either
of us up online and figure out who's
being abused online uh-oh let's look at
some of that oh boy Mr Duff wears rings
on every finger doesn't he misheard
that's my experience yes and they're not
delicate rings are they
uh no they are not
every one of his fingers is adorned your
words big chunky Rings isn't that right
that's my experience of him
and Mr death is always wearing Rings
right Miss heard
that's my experience of him and you've
never known him not to wear these rings
and that's my experience as he normally
wore Rings yes so Mr Depp was wearing
these big chunky rings on every finger
every incident of abuse you've described
to this jury right I can't say for
certain it was in every single incident
but you've never known him not to wear
Rings right in general
um my experience with Johnny is that he
will he wears Rings almost all the time
hmm Mr do you recall giving testimony in
a deposition in this matter in January
of this year I do
can we please play
from your deposition day two
512 page 512 lines 11 through 15.
you said he hit you and he where he he
was wearing Rings right it was hurt so
he hit you with
rings on every finger I don't know if
I've ever known Johnny to not wear rings
Ms heard you testify to an incident in
March of 2013 where Mr Depp hit you in
the face multiple times do you recall
that
that's correct and you testified quote
you don't know how many times he hit you
in the face
that's correct
so Mr Depp hit you in the face multiple
times while he was wearing rings on this
occasion correct
which occasion in March are you
referencing you weren't the testimony
that you gave
on day 15 of this trial
March of 2013 you weren't specific us to
the day
there were several incidents
the one where he hit you several times
in the face
uh
there were there were so I'm sorry just
so I understand better there were
several incidents in March which one are
you asking me about the time that he hit
you several times in the face wearing
rings
well
he pretty much 2013.
right
what are you asking me I'm sorry
he was wearing rings on that occasion I
pretty much always knew him to wear
Rings okay let's please pull up
defendants exhibit 170 a which is
already another will the argument be
that there's no marks from rings
he grabbed me
and hit you in the face so many times
that you don't remember isn't that
correct that's correct
and there's no injuries to your face in
this picture are there not that
picture shows
and there's no medical records
reflecting that you sought treatment
after this alleged incident either
I did not seek medical treatment at this
time
so there's no medical records reflecting
any injuries to your face after hitch he
hit you several times I did not need to
go to the doctor at the time
despite hitting you several times that
you lost count with rings on your on his
fingers that's correct I did not seek
medical attention
other than my therapist
if I to another incident in March of
2013 13 where Mr Depp hit you while he
was wearing a lot of rings
do you remember that testimony
yes ma'am and you testified you felt
like your lip went through your teeth
and it got a little Blood on the wall
yes I remember them
there isn't a picture of you with
injuries after that alleged incident is
there
I don't know if I've seen one
um I I can't recall there are a lot of
pictures
you didn't produce any photographs after
that alleged incident did you I don't
know if I took one or if it's included
I'm not I'm not quite sure which ones
you didn't show any pictures to this
jury after describing that alleged
incident that you're
your teeth
your lip went into your teeth you don't
remember that right people show me
pictures to this jury after describing
that incident right
I don't believe I've seen that picture
admitted
that picture doesn't exist
I I don't know which one you're talking
about there were we had pictures from
March 2013 yes
the only picture that you've produced
and shown to the stories the one that
was just put up on the screen
where you said he hit you multiple times
in the face and you appear to have what
is a bruise on your arm correct I
believe this is the only picture that's
in evidence right now
it's the only picture you've shown to
the story from March 2013. correct I
believe so
he testified about an incident in Russia
on her about June 26 2013. do you
remember that
yes that's correct you testify that Mr
dab quote walk to you in the face
that's correct
and you went to the bathroom after that
right I did
and then according to your testimony
when you came out of the bathroom Jerry
judge Mr death's security guard has
passed away pointed out that your nose
was bleeding right he did that in the
hallway
and you said you hadn't known that your
nose was bleeding until Jerry judge
pointed it out to you
yes that's correct I was unaware until
he brought it up to me I didn't see it
when I was in the bathroom but I wasn't
looking
so so it's your testimony that you went
into the bathroom
and didn't look in the mirror which I
assume was in the bathroom to notice
that your nose is bleeding that's not
why I went into the bathroom I went into
the bathroom
um crying I don't even know if I paid
attention to the mirror I certainly
didn't enough to notice any blood
you didn't take any pictures of your
bloody nose either did you I did not
the pictures were taken of you in Russia
though isn't that correct yes that's
correct we had to press or a dinner
um let's please pull our plaintiff's
exhibit one two four eight
this is extremely delicate when you're
cross-examining someone who says that
they've been abused I think the choice
of having one of the female attorneys do
it is obvious that it's absolutely
necessary for the purposes of the Optics
and you know we'll see ultimately what
the jury finds credible here function I
believe for in promotion of the movie
wasn't the premiere if I recall
you don't have any visible injuries to
your face do you
none that you can see
let's look at plaintiff's exhibit one
two four nine
this is a picture of you isn't it right
that's correct
I'm gonna move to exhibit admit exhibit
one two four nine all right one two four
nine in evidence
this is also a picture from when you
were in Russia for The Lone Ranger
Premiere right that is correct you have
no visible injuries to your face do you
none that you can see
even though Mr death whacked you in the
face so hard that your nose bled
while wearing chunky big Rings right
that's correct
he also testify that Mr depth again
walked you in the face after the Met
Gala in May of 2014 right that is
correct
you testified that you thought he hit
you so hard he broke your nose
that's correct
you said your nose was quote swollen
discolored
red
that is correct I took a picture of that
you testified you took a picture of your
face after this I did
but you didn't show that picture to the
story did you I would like to
didn't show it did you that's not up to
me
hmm
I understand you were under an
obligation to produce all photographs
after any alleged incidents of violence
right misheard I produced everything
didn't produce any photographs after the
Met Gala I produced everything
you also understand that you're under an
obligation to produce all medical
records reflecting any injuries you
allegedly sustained from Mr Depp correct
and that's correct and you haven't
produced any pictures or any medical
records reflecting a broken nose after
the Met gal in May of 2014 have you
I have given everything to my lawyers
everything I've turned over literally
everything that I have well does such a
recording has heard that you sought
medical treatment after Mr Depp
allegedly broke your nose after the Met
Gala not after the Met Gala I did not
seek medical attention no
he also attended an event after the Met
Gala in May of 2014 didn't you that is
correct you went to the All-Star Comedy
tribute to Don Rickles that is correct
that was the next night after the Met
Gala that is correct and there were
pictures of you taken at this event yes
let's please pull up plaintiff's exhibit
one two five two
this is a picture of you misheard
yes it is at that event yes it is the
night after the Met Gala yes it is the
night after Mr Depp allegedly broke your
nose
uh I'm not sure if it was broken for the
record but yeah you should see what it
looked like underneath the makeup
he whacked you so hard in the face you
thought you had broken your nose exactly
right
um permission to admit this photograph
s all right one two five two in evidence
this is a picture of you Mr Depp and Don
Rickles right that is correct
let's please pull up Plankton's exhibit
one two five three
this is another picture from that
evening right Miss heard yes it is
permission to admit exhibit one two five
three and publish it
all right so moved one two five three
and evidence
it's a picture of you and Mr dab
at the event the night after Mr Depp
allegedly whacked him in the face so
hard you thought he had broken your nose
he did whack me in the face and I did
think it broke my nose and this is you
the night after yes it is
let's please pull up plaintiff's exhibit
one two five four
this is also a picture of you at the
same event correctness heard that is
correct
move to admit plaintiff's exhibit one
two five four
all right one two five four in evidence
you can publish
and just to confirm now that the jury
can see it this is a picture of you at
the same event the night after Mr Depp
allegedly locked you in the face so hard
and you thought he broke your nose
this is a picture of me
um after he did whack me in the face the
night after right
yes it is I believe it was the night
after yes
your nose doesn't appear to be injured
in any of these pictures does it
misheard
I'm wearing makeup
your nose doesn't appear to be injured
in any of these pictures does it
misheard
that's why I'm wearing makeup right and
makeup covers up swelling right
makeup will not cover up swelling eyes
well though
ice will cover up swelling
ice reduces swelling normally the
swelling after that kind of injury is
not as bad as you might imagine and for
me
it wasn't that bad I have a picture of
it underneath the makeup that's how I
know how to reference it
a picture you haven't produced or shown
to this jury right Miss heard I
absolutely I've produced everything but
you haven't shown it to the store I
would very much like to it's not my job
hmm
kind of may we approach yes that's fine
so
it's very hard without being in the room
to really get a sense of
you know what the jury is thinking here
my instinct right now is that
this is death any I think a reasonable
jury would at least say
we should consider whether the story she
told under under direct examination is
accurate
uh
but I I think her she's been coached
well enough
that it's not like a disaster yet is my
instinct I don't know what people in the
in the audience think
but I think the building case of all
these injuries that are invisible in
every picture and the pictures that
would show it weren't presented even
though they would strengthen your case
but that's my attorney's fault I don't
know how strong that is
uh if her lawyers didn't produce the
image it must not have been very good
yeah
and remember that this is ultimately
about defamation but the fact of the
defamation would be
if Johnny Depp abused her then by
definition her articles told the truth
and thus it's not defamation because it
was accurate
and so even though it's about who abused
who it's going to the underlying issue
of whether allegations of abuse are
defamatory you also have to in
defamation prove that it was damaging
right like I could say Johnny Depp
abused me it might be inaccurate it is
he didn't abuse me but also if it
doesn't damage him in any way that's an
obstacle to making a defamation case
yeah the lawyers are speaking to the
judge right now
I guess you know from a lay person's
perspective it's hard to imagine why the
most damaging images of Amber Heard
appearing to be injured wouldn't be part
of the case that her lawyers make you
know I don't know that you can really
probe the lawyers you can't probe the
lawyers as to why pictures that may be
good for them weren't shown but it is
weird we as individual lay people can
say if they had the pictures of Amber
Heard looking very injured you'd think
they would become part of the case
unless they thought the pictures weren't
particularly compelling
uh
uh I don't know in the meantime I
believe today it was actually announced
that Johnny Depp has been now formally
dropped from uh Pirates of the Caribbean
the franchise
if I recall correctly
thanks to stoic stranger text strickel
for gifting two subscriptions as well
very much appreciate that
yes of course implicit in all of this is
that the pictures may not exist at all
they may not exist at all that's
absolutely
uh conceivable
without a doubt
hey David I was wondering uh how is
yeah I'm not tech support you'd have to
go ask someone else
so I know
I know maybe some stuff from Egypt is
she talking about Benjamin Shapiro
I don't even know what that's about okay
okay kind of like uh feel hot and cold
response from the chat and from you too
Mr Pac-Man from my uh unplugged
Tenacious D uh stunning rendition so uh
all right we'll do a little more a
little more
[Applause]
rounds
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I really don't know what's
happening I genuinely have no idea
it's very strange very strange thanks to
camera tages for the twitch Prime
subscription I really appreciate that
you're number 22 today
22. uh let me see if I can squeeze in a
little more of the open borders video
from the rally in Texas we'll get back
to the trial as soon as it restarts oh
they're back
okay
Miss heard you testified that in January
of 2015 there was an incident in Tokyo
before Mr def's Mordecai the film
Mordecai's Premiere is that correct
that's correct you told this jury that
on this occasion Mr Depp was kneeling on
your back
that's correct in the closet and you
also told this jury that you wore a
backless dress to the Mordecai Premiere
that very same night
I did
and you testified that you were checking
for bruises in the car on the way back
on the way to the event to make sure
that there were quote no visible marks
right I was checking on my phone
um after the event to see to make sure
that nothing
that you couldn't see anything
your testimony was that you were
checking in the car on the way to the
event
to make sure that there were no marks on
your back
perhaps I misspoke or I misunderstood it
was on the way back from it was after I
was concerned after you know concerned
that there would be marks and any
photographs since we were being
photographed to Johnny's press event
you didn't show this jury a picture of
you in that backless dress though did
you
um I don't know what you mean I'm sorry
you didn't show this jury a picture of
you at the Mordecai premiere
wearing a backless dress did you I
haven't had the opportunity to okay I
assume you have it I do
um let's please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit one two five six
this is a picture of you and Mr Depp or
the back of you
at the Mordecai Premiere in Tokyo
correct Miss heard that is correct your
honor I'd move to admit and publish this
picture all right one two five six in
evidence
[Music]
this is you in the backless dress of the
Mordecai Premiere in Tokyo right
that is correct you would agree that
there are no bruises or visible marks on
your back in this picture no not that I
could see
I'll show you one other photo if we
could please have plaintiff's exhibit
one two five seven
some of these zooms are a little bit
suggestive picture of you and Mr death
at that Premiere correct that is correct
move to admit planche's exhibit
one two five seven all right one two
five seven minutes
I'll show you one more picture
plaintiff's exhibit one two five eight
and again miss heard this is you and Mr
death at the Mordecai premiere yes it is
move to admit plaintiff's exhibit one
two five eight all right one two five
eight in evidence
and that's the backless dress right Miss
heard that is correct
you also told this jury about an
incident in Australia in March of 2015.
yes that's correct
you testify that after this alleged
incident you had cuts on your forearms
right
yes that's true you testified that you
had cuts on the bottoms of your feet as
well
yes that's true
and you testified that you had a bruise
across your jaw from when Mr Depp quote
clocked you in the face end quote
that's true
you didn't take any pictures of these
injuries while you were in Australia did
you
I don't think no I don't think I took
any pictures you just took two pictures
of Mr death's writing on a mirror isn't
that right I believe so yes
so you had your phone on you right
at some point I did have my phone and
your iPad I had my iPad I believe when
you testified that you were also raped
with a liquor bottle in Australia right
Miss heard
yes
you testified you bled from your vagina
as a result of that sexual assault
yes
there aren't any medical records
reflecting that you sought medical
treatment for any of these injuries are
there
I did not seek medical treatment after
Australia no not for the rape
no I did not want to tell anyone not for
the cuts
no not for the injuries to your face I
didn't need to
um
you also told the jury about an incident
on December 15
2015 right
uh where I'm sorry
December 15 2015. yes that's correct you
told this jury that after this incident
you had a broken nose
it certainly felt like it
it's her do you recall giving testimony
on day 16th
in this trial
s right yes
if you have
transcript for the jury
welcome everybody coming from loner
boxes twitch Channel welcome okay all
right we'll we'll get it
in the middle of the cross-examination
of Amber Heard in the Johnny Depp
defamation trial
I will too thank you Judy
foreign
would you like a coffee yes please
foreign
ER to Paige
of day 16 4593
the jury trials transcript
[Music]
foreign
just joining us we'll be live with the
Pennsylvania election results tomorrow
night
lines
8 through 13.
on which page I'm sorry four five nine
three
probably around eight Eastern tomorrow
night
yes
starting on line eight I thought I
probably had a concussion and certainly
thought excuse me let's write that let's
start over I thought I had
I thought I probably had a concussion
and certainly that I had a broken nose
there was a blood everywhere blood all
over the pillows my head was bleeding
from the ripped out hair chunks of hair
on the floor all over the place actually
so lines
nine that I had a broken nose
you recall giving that testimony
misheard yes exactly
so you had a broken nose right that's
absolutely what I thought and you told
the story that you had two black eyes
after this incident right
I did have two black guys after that
incident
and you testified that you also had a
busted lip from when Mr duck punched you
that is uh correct
from December yes that's correct we
testified that the lip wound kept
reopening when you moved your mouth
that's correct
he also testified that you had bruising
on your temple
it's correct
bruising on your chin
correct
you also testified that your head was
bleeding from where Mr Deborah chunks of
your hair out
I remember yes
and that you had quote gross [ __ ]
and quote bruising around your temple
uh in my scalp yeah
now for this incident you did take
pictures
that's correct
and we will look at some of those in a
minute but I first want to talk to you
about your appearance on the James
Corden show sure can I close this sure
you appeared on the James Corden show
the day after this alleged incident
right I did and that was December 16
2015.
yes that's correct
let's please pull up a clip of your
appearance from that evening if we could
plaintiff's exhibit 35 and for the
record we will only be playing a portion
of this so we will call it plaintiff's
exhibit 35a or any objection or 35 a in
evidence
I grew up you know in Texas riding
horses and oh really you know it's not a
big ballet Community out there in Texas
no no not so much shooting guns yes but
ballet no so I wanted to train for it
and there were some ballet sequences uh
that um we wanted to have the option to
to incorporate into the movie so I
trained forever and I two left feet I'm
the most klutzy person in the world and
I have no um
but it's not published to the jury if we
may have it please published okay thank
you apologies if we can please start
that over start over I'm sorry thank you
your honor
but I grew up you know in Texas riding
horses and oh really you know it's not a
big ballet Community out there in Texas
no no not so much shooting guns yes but
ballet no so I wanted to train for it
and there were some ballet sequences
that
um we wanted to have the option to to
incorporate into the movie so I trained
forever and I have two left feet I'm the
most klutzy person in the world and I
have no um
Grace
I knew I had to train for it and what
they don't tell you I mean I and I
crammed about three months of solid
training in and I'm kind of like working
my way up from the floor and learning
the technical aspect of ballet and I've
got these dances down technically
perfectly I'm learning all the movements
but the last thing we get to are the
hands
and I haven't yet got to that point but
everything else is working and I'm
acting it up on my face and I'm selling
the ballet and I think I'm doing really
good at this point kind of nailing it
and so I send videos and and images to
my friends to like get encouragement
look for their support
and everyone's respect what with the
claw hand and I look and I realize like
all that stress and fear of Performing
and doing this thing it just kind of
like funneled out through the one thing
that I hadn't yet like what we all have
I was doing so I'd be doing some amazing
you know I'd be doing like a jump with a
back bend and you can see this like
graceful falling and my hands are like
I've got that you saw on the cliff like
this beautiful 1920s you know stage
makeup on and they hate like flower
crowns and all this stuff and then my
hand and my face and then my hands thank
you
that was you on the James Corden show on
December 16 2015 right Miss heard that
was
please pull up plants exhibit 98.
if you're just joining us the point of
all these exhibits from the
cross-examination perspective is to show
that the injuries she claimed she had
she didn't really have
um like screen grabs
Stills they're not like a it's like a
photo shoot it doesn't seem
but on the James Corden show correct
from that appearance yes
move to admit and publish plaintiff's
exhibit 98. all right and Mr Speaker you
could move the microphone and turn it on
for you so Judy and I are having trouble
hearing you sorry about that all right
thank you all right 98 in evidence thank
you
that's a photo of you opening your mouth
on the right right that's correct
and again a larger view the same photo
on the bottom
that's correct with a split lip
you've seen pictures of it without
makeup
yeah so you've had a split lip when you
screwed it in your mouth that way I sure
did in those photographs absolutely
you did take pictures of your alleged
injuries on after December 15th correct
and you showed those to this jury
I sure did yes okay let's please pull up
defendants exhibit 516 which is already
in evidence
[Music]
you testified that this is a picture of
you after the incident on December 15
2015 right it was
and if we could also please pull up
defendants exhibit 517 which is also an
Evidence
it's fun thanks for your honor this is
also a picture of you after the incident
on December 15 2015.
that's correct
if we could please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 409 which is already in evidence
[Applause]
these pictures ended up in People
magazine in June of 2016. isn't that
right Miss heard that's correct
you gave these pictures to People
magazine after you publicly accused Mr
death of domestic abuse didn't you I
didn't personally know
this is you protecting Mr Depp after you
got the restraining order against him
isn't it no this is him calling me a
liar and me forcing to prove it
as I mentioned to you earlier so you did
give these pictures to People magazine
No I gave these um pictures actually to
my lawyers and my Representatives at the
time so it's your testimony misheard
that your lawyers and representatives
gave these pictures of their client to
People magazine in the middle of a
contentious divorce I certainly did not
personally give it no
personal
hmm
you also have a medical record from
after the December but they must have
agreed that the lawyer would provide it
right I mean that only makes sense yes
we went to see Dr Kipper's office a
couple days later
that's right he wasn't in the office
can we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 47 which is already in evidence
this is your medical record for December
17 2015 isn't it misheard
that's correct
and this record doesn't document any
physical injuries on you does it
I I don't think so no I I don't think I
spoke
to Kipper I didn't speak to Kipper
um that day
and you guys to Dr Kipper's office and
we're seeing correct I went to Dr Kipper
off went to Dr Kipper's office for a
concussion check right okay and this
medical record is from that visit
correct
partially yes
scroll down please if we could
thank you
the signature Kipper down below this is
the entirety of the medical record right
Miss heard yes what I meant by partial
is I didn't talk about what happened to
me I didn't get into my injuries I
didn't get into what happened or um
asked for anything other than should I
get some sort of scan done
all right but this record doesn't
document any physical injuries on you
does it
uh I'd have to read it in full but I I
don't know well let's do that
we could please go
well under skin on the second page
it reads intact normal color moisture
hair distribution texture trigger
no signs of oh this is gonna be hard
cyanosis
come on
It also says I'm a well-nourished male
right
I have no idea what that means I I think
this medical record's missing a lot of
things
doesn't seem to be documenting anything
probably because there was nothing to
document right Miss heard I disagree
with
you yeah it doesn't have any medical
records reflecting that you broke your
nose during your relationship with Mr
death do you
uh I saw an ENT after my relationship
ended
and you saw an e and it's your testimony
under oath that you saw an ENT for
broken noses that you sustained as a
result of Mr death no but the ENT told
me Isis objection full fractures
so again just to
try my question there's no medical
records reflecting that you broke it
seems that she was trying to say that
the ENT verbally told her her nose was
broken but there's no record so that it
was struck documented that um visit and
that everything was given to my
attorneys misheard you never went to see
any doctor or surgeon
to treat a broken nose during your
relationship with Mr Depp yes or no I
never sought treatment for broken nose
while I was with Johnny
or after you were with Mr Depp as a
result of any injuries you sustained as
a result of Mr Depp afterwards yes I did
and you didn't produce those medical
records in this case I'm an eject your
honor she did I did I I don't know all
right they have not been produced
um
so again part of the thing here I think
comes to
well people filing out all of a sudden
of the courtroom
um the question of being produced
Amber Heard is insisting that she has
produced them to her attorneys
but her attorneys have not made them
part of the trial
but I don't think if if they're if
they're not in evidence it just doesn't
seem that it's of any value for her to
say well I they exist but my lawyers
aren't using them I don't know
I'd be interested to hear from
lawyers in the audience about that
you don't have any medical records
reflecting that you're requiring dental
work during your relationship with Mr
duck do you
uh I don't know
I don't work I don't recall
you don't recall one way or another
seeking dental care for any injuries you
allegedly sustained
uh you asked me about if I had produced
records or if I had records that's a
different question
did you ever see a dentist or an oral
surgeon
as a result of any injuries you
sustained with Mr Depp not
about any injury I had from Johnny no
and you don't have any medical records
reflecting that you required any
reconstructive work during your
relationship with Mr Duff do you I never
required reconstructive work
so there would be no records
what you do have misheard are pictures
of Mr Depp sleeping though right
the jury saw a lot of those
yes
sir let's take a look at defendants
exhibit 1090 which is already in
evidence
you took this Photograph right Miss
heard that's correct
and you testified that this was taken in
Tokyo in July of 2013 correct
yes
so you decided to take a picture of Mr
Depp asleep on the floor
he was passed out
and I took a picture of him because he
uh wouldn't remember he claimed he
didn't pass out that way and sometimes
security would carry him like a baby
into bed and get him changed and he
would be none the wiser so I started
taking pictures of it so that he knew
that it was real that it had gotten this
bad
let's take a look at defendants exhibit
1091 which is already in evidence
foreign
you took this picture as well yes
this is the picture that was taken in
the Bahamas right
it's one of them yes
and this is a picture of Mr Duff taking
a nap on his tropical island
I believe he was on the nod but as he
would say
sleeping on the nod
on his Island they're very different in
my opinion
and yes he is on the island
on vacation
uh we were on vacation yes
let's also take a look at defendants
exhibit 1092 which is also an Evidence
we also took this picture right Miss
heard that's correct I did and this is
another picture of Mr Depp asleep in a
chair
no he was um nodding off uh sleep is
different when you're nodding off you're
high on drugs didn't even feel the
cigarette in his hand that had you know
been burning on his leg uh was caused
for alarm for me naturally
um because I cared about him
uh it's your testimony under oath that
Mr Depp is holding a cigarette in this
picture he had been
seemed to really like taking pictures of
Mr Depp while he's sleeping don't you I
hated it I hated it
let's look at defendants exhibit 1094
which is also an Evidence
he took this picture of Mr death as well
didn't you I did you decided to take a
picture of Mr Depp asleep with ice cream
spilled all over him right
he was nodding off and I was worried
about how bad the medications and the
medication change and the drug use has
had gotten or he wouldn't even fill ice
cream or a lit cigarette on him and it
scared me a picture of it yes I um I
wanted him to get help and Johnny's
surrounded by enablers who clean up
after him I'm gonna move to strike
everything after yes that she took this
picture it's still responsive here on it
the question was did you take this
picture all right I'll sustain the
objection thank you your honor
this isn't a very flattering picture of
Mr Depp is it no it's not you wouldn't
agree that this is or you would agree
with me that this is an embarrassing
scene right
yes I think it's a part of getting help
is looking at it and seeing it but you
sent this picture to one of your friends
didn't you
I don't recall
[Music]
um if we could please pull up defendants
exhibit 252
only be looking at the portion of this
document so if we could please call it
defendants exhibit 252a
five two eight and for ease we've gone
ahead and redacted it
yes I was asking for support
that's correct
it's no question yet miss heard so
directing your attention I'm going to
move to admit
um exhibit 252a any objection
any objection Mr Fredo
could you turn turn on could you turn
your microphone again sir
thank you
uh I need to see it first because I
don't know what they redacted two five
two we redacted the identifiers
and anything that's not misheards text
messages
consistent with hearsay
thanks to chicken parm for the five
gifted Subs I saw that and I do
appreciate it didn't want to interrupt
the testimony
you remember we approach okay
so presumably what's at issue here is
that she said she doesn't remember Amber
Heard says she doesn't remember whether
she texted the ice cream picture to
anyone my guess is they have text
messages showing that she did uh that
would be my guess I want to say thanks
to Juan the troll man for gifting
another subscription today that's number
31 that subscription goes to Caitlyn
Genovese you can request a free
membership at davidpackman.com free
membership also so thanks to man eunuch
menu Nick for the twitch Prime
subscription you're number 32. I believe
this should go to the top of the hour
are you guys aware of whether this goes
until 5 or 5 30 Eastern today I don't
actually remember one way or the other
uh tomorrow night around 8 Eastern I'll
be live with Pennsylvania Senate results
we've got the Democratic primary the
Republican primary a number of other
elections as well
yes she did seem to admit it before a
question was even asked but since
there's there was no question asked I
don't believe that utterance is part of
the record correct me if I'm wrong
yeah they're having um
they're having pretty pretty massive uh
technical issues here
let me see if I have my technical issues
section and our incredible oh these
people don't know what the hell they're
doing
the bike
let me recover my ears for one second
yep uh whoever typically runs audio at
the Trump rallies seems to be doing it
for the court as well
that's that's for damn sure yeah
okay let's see if now I can get to a
little bit of our open borders video for
the audience what that sign is all about
uh this thing is about uh open border
yeah you know every country protects the
the countries the People by the border
every country have a border why
didn't open their border sure but you're
you understand that at the border
thousands upon thousands of people are
getting detained every single day and
thousands of people are being deported
so we're enforcing the Border just maybe
not as much as you would like
well I don't think I don't think
thousand people is the partner I think
nobody's deported right now the
deportation stopped on the day Joe Biden
became so does this
special recollection that you did in
fact send this picture to your friend
Rocky Pennington yes I did
he sent it to her
on August 7 2014 at 11 24 PM correct
that is correct
so you sent Miss Pennington this picture
of Mr duck with ice cream spilled on him
right that is correct and you wrote
quote this is what I've been dealing
with end quote did I read that right you
did read that right that's correct and
this is you protecting Mr dupp
that is me getting support from my best
friend this is you supporting Mr Depp
this is me getting support from my best
friend I also need support
you weren't afraid the the monster would
get upset that you took this picture
This was um opiate Johnny
this is uh different
version of him this is opiate on the nod
Johnny and you weren't afraid that Opia
Johnny or the monster as you called him
would get upset that you sent this
picture to your friend well he's all of
those things if we of course he could
get upset and of course that's scary to
me of course but I'd stop you from
sending this picture to your friend did
it why would it
Mr Duff's hand right hand is in his
pocket right Miss heard that's correct
he also showed this jury pictures of
cocaine do you recall that
yes that's correct
please take a look at one of those if we
could please pull up defendant's exhibit
167 a which is already in evidence
there's been a question as to whether
the cross-examination would push on
Amber heard's claim I believe that she's
not used cocaine we'll see if that's
what they're getting to here directing
your attention is heard to
photograph this is a photograph you took
in March of 2013 right that is correct
and this was taken at your apartment in
Orange yes
and this is your breakfast table that is
correct
and it's your testimony that Mr duck
left this breakfast table just the way
you took it
that is correct
so this is what the table looked like
after Mr death had been doing cocaine
uh well clearly he has yet to snort
these lines
there are four lines of cocaine on this
table right Miss heard in this picture I
see four lines
there isn't any cocaine residue around
those lines right
uh I not that I can tell no
doesn't really look like anyone's been
doing cocaine off that table does it
with all due respect I'm not sure you
know how that works I'm asking if you do
you've testified you've done cocaine I
have
doesn't really look like Mr Depp or
anyone was doing cocaine off that table
does it uh I beg to differ with you on
that when you snort cocaine typically it
goes into your nose
and then it doesn't stay on your table
there's residue from that cocaine when
your lips and nose touch the table right
will the tampon applicator next to
um
the
credit I mean a driver's license that
you see is
a device that I believe my sister had
taught him
to use in order to
put the cocaine
uh in your nose
Mr death is a pretty heavy smoker right
he is
and and that's a cigarette in the
ashtray in the back there
um back right yes it looks like one of
his hand rolls
just no other cigarettes in that ashtray
are there I see one cigarette
the one that's not smoked
that's correct
there's no Ash in that ashtray either is
there
uh not that I can tell in this picture
it's pretty clean
in this picture it looks like it yes
it's a pretty neat table wouldn't you
agree
um
depends on what you would call neat I
suppose and you sent this picture to
your friend Rocky Pennington as well
didn't you I sure did
and when you sent it you said quote look
at my morning or something like that is
that right yay for mornings
so you have a habit of sending stage
photographs to your friend Rocky don't
you I had a habit of communicating with
my best friend about what was going on
in my life
cocaine do
you I don't think I have a picture of
him mids snort no
you don't even have any pictures of Mr
dupp with cocaine what do you mean by
that
holding cocaine standing next to cocaine
um
sitting next to cocaine I don't know I
don't know well you haven't shown any of
those pictures like that to the jury
have you I don't know I no I haven't
and you were never able to catch Mr Depp
with cocaine on film either
were you I never tried
but you were able to catch him sleeping
right
I have seen him pass out in all sorts of
places yes
and you also captured a video of Mr Depp
in the kitchen that was played again for
this jury today uh beating up some
cabinets do you recall that
sorry say that again you recall
capturing Mr death in the kitchen of one
of his homes
beating up some cabinets
yes
slamming things around yes so you took
that video of Mr death in the kitchen
right I did I did you took it on one of
your iPad devices I took it on my iPad
you were deposed in August of 2016 in
connection with your divorce proceedings
from Mr Depp right that is correct and
you will recall that the video of Mr
Depp in the kitchen was released online
the day before real quick is the
argument about that picture that like
there's an unsmoked cigarette no ashes
four lines of cocaine that are
undisturbed and that is the idea it's
unlikely that Johnny Depp would set all
that up and then leave I remember
learning about it when I landed so it's
just a coincidence that the video you
took of Mr dapp was released the day
before you were deposed in connection
with your divorce Mr death I absolutely
had nothing to do with that I wouldn't
even know how to do something like that
thank you
he settled your divorce for Mr death in
August of 2016 right
that sounds right
and in connection with that settlement
he received a seven million dollars from
Mr Depp true that's correct
and then 2.8 exactly
Your settlement amount was seven million
dollars that's correct
and then you released a statement in
which you claimed you would be donating
the entire seven million dollars to
charity right that's correct
you say that you would be donating half
of the seven million dollars to the ACLU
that's correct and you would be donating
the other half to Children's Hospital of
Los Angeles that's correct and you also
stated with respect to the seven million
dollar divorce settlement that money
played no role except for the extent
that you could donate the money to
charity
that's correct
please pull up plaintiff's exhibit 1259
is it disputed that the money was
ultimately donated this is an article
entitled Amber Heard donates Johnny Depp
divorce settlement to charity read her
statement in full
is that correct that's what the title
says I don't know if they've disputed
directing your attention to the portion
on the second page where it says quote
read the statement below
is that the statement You released
misheard
that is correct
your honor I'd move to admit the
statement and the article as redacted
objection hearsay
it's her statement
it this is not her statement this is
some she just testified her honor that's
your statement
may I see the full uh everything else is
redacted
um
okay then I have no objection all right
one two five nine and evidence has
redacted
statement reads
as described in the restrainian order
and divorce settlement money played no
role for me personally and never has
except to the extent that I could donate
it to charity and in doing so hopefully
help those less able to defend
themselves
as reported in the media the amount
received in the divorce was 7 million
dollars and seven million dollars is
being donated this is over and above any
funds that I have given away in the past
and will continue to give away in the
future
did I read that correctly
that is correct I don't remember that
last line but I have no
it doesn't stand out to me is wrong
there's nothing inaccurate in the
statement not that I recognize no
Mr Depp donated a hundred thousand
dollars of the divorce settlement
directly to the ACLU is that right
right at the beginning of the divorce
settlement he
um donated a hundred thousand to each
charity on my behalf or towards my
contribution so hundred thousand dollars
to each to the ACLU and to the
Children's Hospital
and in response you publicly demanded
that Mr Debt Pay the divorce settlement
directly to you instead of the Charities
right that was always the agreement
actually is for him to pay me directly
it was not his money as per the
settlement agreement to give away and
reap a tax benefit from
I said if he wants to do it and give to
charity all of a sudden then he should
pay the correct amount and not try to
get a big tax break for it so
effectively for his tax bracket he
should be paying double that amount to
the charity directly and if you wanted
to pay the charity directly he could
he could do that was fine with me but he
would need to pay the adjusted amount
hmm ultimately the rest of the seven
million divorce settlement was paid
directly to you right over time yes Mr
depth didn't end up paying the rest of
the seven million divorce settlement
directly to the Charities you identified
that is correct he paid them
installments to me you thought that from
happening didn't you
I don't understand what your question is
I'm sorry you stopped Mr Depp from
paying the Charities that you had named
directly that is incorrect I said if you
want to pay the Charities directly pay
the adjusted amount or pay is per our
agreement in the settlement or in the
divorce
as per our agreement
and he chose to do the former not the
latter I mean the other way around
you also publicly stated that the seven
million dollar divorce settlement should
be paid to the Charities immediately in
full right
if he wanted to pay it in the way that
he was suggesting yes and and you said
publicly that the payments to the
Charities should not be drawn out over
many years right
I said that I don't I don't recall the
exact words that I used but basically
that he shouldn't use this as an a novel
interest in getting a tax break that if
he wanted to do that and not pay me the
settlement that was fine but he would
have to pay the adjusted amount and not
make it you know a a commitment he would
not fulfill or try to avoid in some
other way
and that's because you wanted the entire
world to think that you were donating
every penny of a seven million divorce I
think that's legit like if it's like if
it's 7 million to her that as a
settlement wouldn't be tax deductible if
he donates 7 million to Charities it is
it seems legit for her to say no he
can't get a three million dollar tax
break for the 7 million donation he
should donate 10 million instead that
seems logical to me didn't you
see if we can refresh the recollection
because understand the idea would be if
he donates the 7 million and it's tax
deductible and he pays 42 tax or
whatever it is based on being California
45-46 it's almost like he really only
paid 3.8
this is an article entitled Amber Heard
and Johnny Depp row over divorce
donations
and if I could direct your attention to
where it says
I believe it's on the second page
her spokeswoman responded in the
statement
the language that follows the statement
it's not her right a spokesperson is an
exception your honor you want to come
forward
so now the issue is that they are going
to argue as to whether it's hearsay or
if there is an exception for a
spokesperson specifically speaking on
the behalf of an individual
um in the meantime if you're just
joining us such Professor Jordan B
Peterson has gone after me on Twitter
we looked at that earlier it's very very
strong
let's see how that is looking I just
responded with a yikes I don't plan on
engaging further
uh not a very high engagement tweet
my stupid one word response has a third
of the likes yeah anyway he didn't like
my clip about him weeping recently
um
really You released a statement we
approach again okay
they're approaching again we'll watch a
few more seconds of our video from on
the ground in Texas over the weekend yes
thousands of people are being deported
before or no no no no under under Joe
Biden
you imagine
yeah that's if you just disagree with
something you just go nah now of course
people are being deported under Biden
uh
uh and it's wild to think that
no one's being deported anymore but they
are we'll have I believe that clip is
the Full Clip is live in 35 minutes on
our YouTube channel I believe
and that is going to be a good one to
watch
yeah before we ask the next question
I'll just hand you a copy
one of my favorite phrases in political
debate is just nah
all right
another one I like is urn
that's right that's right thank you
yes yes welcome everybody we're just
watching the defamation trial here
um currently Amber Heard is being
cross-examined
could you please turn your microphone on
I'm sorry I was growing up
Meister um they gave me a redacted but I
don't have the unredacted to be able to
see the fall I plan to admit it or ask
that it'd be admitted in redacted form
I'm taking away any hearsay and I'm just
trying to lay the foundation but this is
a statement she released through a
spokesperson how would I know whether
there's more to it that shouldn't be
redacted your honor if I don't see the
full document
thank you
please proceed governor
that's a fair question
sort of like where are the pictures that
don't exist which picture that doesn't
exist the witness can testify as to
whether this is a full statement or not
the witness can't do we have the right
to be able to see the documentary do you
have a document that's not redacted we
can pull it up on our computers okay
just give us a moment
I can represent this is the full
statement that's recorded
a lot of technical stuff it's
unredactical
millibyte
millibyte megabyte uncharged piccolos
these trials get so technical you know
pixels and millibytes
megabytes oh Super Chat came in this
whole trial I've noticed a lot of
hearsay objections being enforced very
well said
indeed
this is supposed to be over by Memorial
Day the judge said she will be sticking
to it extremely strongly from what she
said
we're getting late into the day as you
can see from the angle of the Sun in the
courthouse
some call it magic hour I would never
call it that but some do we'll be live
tomorrow with the Pennsylvania results
looks like they're almost in agreement
here
okay
here's a quick voicemail for you
I'm fairly audible I'm not going to
subject you to that
David David a copy of this yeah
you can get a copy that
uh happily later later yesterday okay
right I think she should be giving us
copies of the phone well I understand
but we'll take care of that but okay as
of right now can we continue are you we
can hear anybody have an objection
because of
quotations
okay come forward uh oh there's
quotation marks
here's a voicemail and more more
problems with lawsuits related to
machines apparently
David uh I just wanted to reach out to
say that I'm very very afraid uh for my
Breville uh my Breville Barista Express
b-e-s-870xl espresso machine that's a
beautiful machine that's the one I have
in stainless steel is
uh facing 30 Years to Life uh because of
like lindel our friend Mike pillow
um his lawsuit so please pray for my
espresso machine
I would I I cannot uh pay for his legal
defense so
um my my espresso machine is actually
going to be represented by celebrity
lawyer Mark garagos we're doing a class
action
suit against all machines
[Music]
we're all going to be on manual
toothbrushes soon my friends
Jarrett says love the stream keep up the
good work
it's called Golden hour David what did I
call it did I not call it golden hour
what did I say so directing your
attention Miss heard where it says her
spokeswoman responded in a statement
you're telling which that follows
the language that follows all right we
if you want to lay the foundation to
that go ahead You released a statement
after Mr Depp donated a hundred thousand
dollars to the ACLU and a hundred
thousand dollars to chla correct Miss
heard I think so yes okay
and the language that follows is the
statement You released
in response to Mr def's donations right
I don't know if this is this the
official statement I really I have no
idea
the salmon that reads starts action your
honor Amber Heard that's the only thing
I'm going to say would you please read
that to yourself it's hard
hmm
Amber heard's lawyer is not a fan of
this
not a fan one bit
yes
did you read all the way to the very
bottom where the last word is supported
did you really read it is what she's
saying
thanks dribbly Bob for the twitch Prime
subscription yes okay that's the
statement You released through your
spokeswoman after Mr debt made their
donations to the chla and the ACLU
correctness heard I do not recall
exactly what my statement was
I don't disagree with anything in the
statement but I just simply don't recall
what the statement was we released is
there anything inaccurate in that
statement miss her no
I'm going to move to admit Jackson
you're on a lack of foundation our
Overworld objection one two six zero in
evidence it's in thank your honor
reads Amber Heard appreciates Johnny
Depp's novel interest in supporting two
of her favorite cherries the ACLU
American civil liberties Union for
domestic violence and the Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles
great and unexpected news
and it continues
however if Johnny wishes to change the
settlement agreement we must insist that
he honor the full amount by donating 14
million dollars to charity which after
accounting for his tax deduction is
equal to his seven million dollar
payment obligation to Amber
and it continues
we would also insist that the full
amount be paid immediately and not drawn
out over many years anything less would
be a transparent attempt by Johnny's
Council Laura wasser and Patty Glaser to
reduce their clients true payment by
half under the guise of Newfound concern
for Charities that he has never
previously supported end quote
did I read that correctly yes
thank you
after this you kept commenting about the
donation of your divorce settlement
right
uh I don't know what you mean by that
I spoke about donating your divorce
settlement on a Danish TV show correct
uh I believe I said I had
um
I I believe I said I donated it to
charity but it was already printed or
already
commented on and stated in the Press I
had already released that information in
the Press I think I just confirmed it on
that show you appeared on a show called
RTL late night right I don't recall it
which show it was
please play plaintiff's exhibit three
four six which is a portion of your
appearance on this program
and we would ask that it'd be moved into
evidence and ask for permission to
publish it it contains it has hearsay it
contains other Communications with other
individuals your honor if we may
approach very briefly
wow they're gonna make it difficult
that's for sure
I David I'm confused about this idea
that a woman can be convicted for murder
if she has like an abortion or whatever
couldn't you convict the fetus because
it's a full person for like attempted
murder or something like that
if the fetus jeopardizes the life of the
mother
could you charge the fetus with
attempted murder on the basis of the
crate I mean like this I hope you guys
understand this is all under the crazy
right-wing idea on this stuff could you
could you charge the fetus
uh
uh I mean if you could and it's a state
with the death penalty there's no intent
ah Fair that's fair there's no intent
thanks to 222 Damo for the twitch Prime
subscription that's number 36 also
thanks to dribbly Bob and deranged
socialite for the additional gifts and
Subs I very much appreciate that to be
involuntary manslaughter I guess is what
we're saying
yeah I mean it's like
when you create an insane framework it
leads to Crazy questions for sure
um
Speak oh speaking of which I have
something on this from the Texas rally
that we were at check this out it
actually is about exactly this
um so big news Roe v Wade looks like
it's gonna be overturned yeah what was
your reaction to that
it's great it was horrible you know
horrible uh ruling in the first place uh
and all they've done is Muddy it up
since then so I think uh it's about time
okay and then in your ideal country what
would the rules slash laws be on people
getting abortions
that's the right to life life starts at
conception uh it's science you know this
is a human life
okay we should protect life always and
the punishment if you got an abortion
what do you think when you take a life
an innocent life
should be murder
Ed oh it should be murder you know say
you should be murdered
like should the person get that penalty
yes please
and actually there were all kinds of
accusations uh flying your way when you
said all this and then there was a
divorce
what the heck
what just happened
should we try switching over here
and actually were all kinds of
accusations uh flying your way when you
said all this and then there was a
divorce settlement you got seven million
dollars people were saying this is all
about the money but then you did
something that uh Twisted that whole
argument what did you do with that money
seven million dollars in total was
donated to him I split it between the
ACLU and Children's Hospital of Los
Angeles ACLU is a human rights
organization sorry ACLU is a prominent
um uh organization non-profit
organization in the United States it's
called the American civil liberties
Union and they work on behalf of
marginalized communities uh on the
ground and the legislative reform and
well more power to you because that's
that's something that I've never wanted
nothing
okay let's maybe go back over here
without knowing when it was recorded I
have no idea
7 million
dollar to you in full by February of
2018. right that's correct
let's take a look at defendant's exhibit
1458 which is already in evidence
this is the deal Point memorandum from
your divorce settlement right Miss heard
yes that's what it looks like
and if we go down to the bottom of page
four
there's a heading labeled
equalization payment do you see that yes
and underneath
why do we keep losing audio here it's
very weird
that's on their end just for everybody
to know it's not that's not anything
we're having over here
should we just abandon and stick here
let's see
equalization payment do you see that yes
and underneath that it outlines the
payment schedule for the divorce
payments correct
uh yes or begins to and if we go on page
page five
so the first payment is scheduled for
August 31st 2016 and that's 200 000
correct yes that is correct
Mr Duff's accountant Edward White
testified that he made that payment
directly
you got to turn on your microphone Mr
Hoff I am not going to hear you
objection to her testifying to what Mr
White testified to that okay it's that
actual it he literally testified to it
in court all over world objection thank
you your honor Mr def's accountant
Edward White testified that he made the
payment directly to the ACLU and chla
correct I believe so yes
and then the rest of the payments were
all made to you weren't they that is
correct and the final payment of 2.3
million dollars is on February 1st 2018
right the final payment yes and you were
here in court when Mr White testified
the payments were all made on schedule
I'm an object to her testifying to what
Mr White testified to it's over
objection go ahead thank you your honor
and you were here in court when Mr White
testified that the payments were all
made on schedule right
I don't believe they were uh he might
have tested my question Miss heard my
question was you were here in court when
Mr White testified under oath
that all the payments were made on
schedule
I was here every day in court I I heard
his testimony yes okay
so back to October of 2018 this was
before Mr death sued you for deformation
correct
yes that's correct he didn't sue you
until after the op-ed came out in
December of 2018 right he sued me in
2019.
and the op-ed came out in December of
2018. that is correct so in October of
2018 you had received your entire seven
million divorce settlement you agree
with me that is correct
and you hadn't yet been sued by Mr dupp
this is uh
October correct
so in this October 2018 interview you
said that you had quote donated
end quote your entire divorce settlement
to charity right that's correct and in
fact your exact words were quote seven
million in total was donated to I split
it between the ACLU and the Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles end quote right
that's correct I made that statement as
soon as I got a divorce and we reached
the settlement that's when I pledged it
right then
and you say this because you quote
wanted nothing end quote that is correct
but you hadn't donated your entitled
entire seven million dollars settlement
to charity at that point had you that's
incorrect
sitting here today Miss heard you still
haven't donated the seven million
dollars divorce settlement to charity
isn't that right
incorrect I pledged the entirety of the
settlements
I intend to fulfill those obligations oh
I intend that's not my question uh oh
please try to answer my question
sitting here today you have not donated
the seven million dollars donated now
pledged donated the seven million
dollars divorce settlement to charity
I use Pledge and donation synonymous oh
no
if this show was based on the pledges
we've received rather than the money you
should see what our studio would look
like that's not my question
as of today
you have not paid 3.5 million dollars of
your own money to the ACLU yes or no
I have not yet
and as of today you have not paid 3.5
million dollars of your own money to the
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles
correct I have not yet Johnny sued me so
as of today you have not donated
paid seven million dollars of your
divorce settlement to charity right
I have not been able to fulfill those
those obligations yet
and that's because you did want
something
didn't you I didn't want anything and I
didn't get anything you wanted Mr Duff's
money
didn't get it wasn't interested in it I
loved Johnny that's why I was with him
you wanted praise for donating the money
right that's incorrect you wanted good
press
in general one does want good press yes
you want it to seem altruistic publicly
wasn't my interest my interest is uh in
my name and clearing my name and at the
time I was being called a liar and my
motives were being questioned I did see
it as important to
clear that up I wanted to make a
statement to make sure that there was
not any doubt that I couldn't be labeled
these things just because Johnny was a
bigger star and had more publicity reach
I wanted to remind every one of your
claims of domestic violence against Mr
Depp right no I wanted to move on with
my life you wanted to make those claims
seem believable
they are believable they wanted them to
be seen you wanted to be seen excuse me
as a noble victim of domestic violence I
have to never never wanted to be seen as
a victim
nor have I ever called myself one
you testified under oath that quote the
entirety of your divorce settlement was
donated to charity end quote didn't you
that's correct I pledged the entirety
no pledge Miss heard my questions
your Council will have time to redirect
you
after
you testified under oath quote the
entirety of your divorce settlement was
donated
to charity end quote that is correct I
pledged the entirety oh my God I'm gonna
move to strike everything after yes
all right
Miss hurt is it really inappropriate
I'll sustain the objection and we'll
just move forward let's move forward
next question
under oath that statement wasn't true
was it misheard
I'm sorry I don't follow your question
sorry did you lie
you testified under oath quote the
entirety of my divorce settlement was
donated to charity end quote that
statement wasn't true
it is true I pledged the entirety to
charity oh man statement when you say
you buy a house you don't pay in this
entire house exactly yes yes you do the
mortgage company pays it thank you
that statement isn't true today you
don't buy it until all the money's there
it is true I pledged the entirety but
you didn't donate it
unfortunately you didn't donate it's a
yes or no I haven't been able to
obligate I mean to fulfill those so
that's a no right Miss heard I am I made
the pledge I want to be very clear I
pledge the entirety I haven't been able
to fulfill those pledges because I've
been sued you have so the statement a
million dollars for 13 months before Mr
Depp sued you and you chose not to pay
it to the Charities you pledged it to
isn't that correct I disagree with your
characterization of that
thank you
let's look at your sworn testimony from
the UK Dear God
I didn't think the cross-examination was
going that well but this this is pretty
bad because the entire Jury has to
realize that it's a lie to say I donated
it all when she pledged it
thank you
thanks dribbly Bob for gifting five more
subs on Twitch
appreciate that there's this light
coming across them so I appreciate that
it's probably good light
thank you your honor all right
oh it looks like it was a reflection
from the Skylight off of the lectern
that that was that's a crazy angle huh
or maybe it's not
witness statement that you submitted K
action right Miss heard correct and the
statement was made under oath true that
is true I'm directing your attention to
the last page
of that statement
that's your signature right
yes it is so you made the sworn
statement on February 26 2000
2020.
that's correct
and directing your attention to
paragraph four
it says
quote I remained financially independent
from him the whole time we were together
and the entire amount of my divorce
settlement was donated to charity end
quote that is correct did I read that
correctly yes you did the hymn you were
referring to is Mr Duff that is correct
most of the money that was donated to
the ACLU and chla in your name came from
someone else isn't that right
I don't know what you mean by most stuff
well at least five hundred thousand
dollars that was donated to the ACLU and
your name wasn't paid by you right uh I
believe Elon made a donation in my honor
on one of one of the years yeah and it
didn't come out of your seven million
divorce settlement right no nor did it
count towards my pledge
and at least five hundred thousand
dollars that was donated to the
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles and
your name wasn't paid by you either
right those were made at the same time
and it didn't come out of your seven
million divorce settlement nor did it
count to why three point let's switch
over here
right
hold on a second I apologize for this
[ __ ] your patient patience and either in
your uh looks like it's over seven
million dollar divorce settlement for
yourself right I'm very wrong about that
I think this if you're on our response
this is a good stuff Breaking Point okay
that's fine all right ladies and
gentlemen we'll stop here for the
evening remember tonight do not do any
outside research and not discuss the
case with anybody I know these days are
a little longer and I appreciate your
patient patience and and you know in
your uh taking care of everything here
please take care of yourself tonight
okay and we'll see in the morning at 9am
all right so this last bit to me as a
layperson doesn't seem like it was great
for Amber Heard uh the the uh you know
at this point it's very clear that she
said I'm going to donate it it wasn't
all donated she did make multiple
statements saying I did donate it all
now she's saying pledge and donate or
the same thing pledges a promise a
pledge is a promise a pledge is a
promise it's not a donation we've
received many pledges here on the
program I've had people say David I'm
going to pledge uh we had we had a great
situation where someone said hey we I
run a Family Trust and we have to donate
the interest every year and
um I'm gonna make a pledge so that we're
gonna do I forget what amount it was
every year to the David packman show
they pledged it we didn't see any of it
they disappeared imagine if they said no
we donated it well but did you transfer
the money no but I pledged it no I think
we understand that that doesn't make any
sense so that is going to be the end for
today we will be back tomorrow with
um the results live results of the
Pennsylvania Senate race which is a
major major race make sure you're
following on Twitch make sure you are
subscribed free on YouTube and make sure
you've liked on Facebook we'll be live
on all three platforms tomorrow and keep
your machines safe my friends we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines absolutely we'll see everybody
tomorrow
foreign